- I had real long hair then,
just got out of prison.
- 14 years.
- Wow. That's a crazy story.
- I done done it all.
You name it I done it.
- All right, what do they call you?
- Call me Smiley Ru.
- Smiley Ru?
- East Side 30 Piru Gang.
- Piru. Uh, Piru's are... It's Blood's?
- Bloods.
- Bloods. Okay
- Uh-hmm.
- And, you joined... you joined
them at what... what age?
- 13.
- 14. Probably a little younger,
but when I really got
active was like 13, 14.
- Yeah.
- What I mean by active, I was uh...
I was full fledge with the business.
Back then we had zip guns, 22's, 25's.
I'm 52 years old.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
All the dudes I grew up
with dead or got life.
- Ooh.
- But I was the one that
was voted to get life.
Cause I was too wild.
- Yeah.
- But God had other plans for me.
I done worked... I done
work doing construction.
I done worked for the city of Pasadena,
Home Depot. Everywhere.
God showed me another side.
At the same time, I'm
human. I'm not perfect.
Then I slipped back to the wrong side.
Maybe I didn't slip.
Maybe that was part of the
God's plan, his design
for me to get a good look,
to make a better choice when it's time
to make the real choice.
But in between all of that,
Hell.
- Ha. When is the first
time you went to prison?
How old were you?
I... Why, I was 17 years old.
They gave me 14 years
for attempted murder.
- Hmm.
- I did till I was 25. I got out.
I caught a murder. I fought
that for like 3,4 years.
I got out. I stayed out like 5 years.
Kinda grew big up in a dope game. Uh...
Kinda concentrated, got married.
Kinda concentrated more on my family.
Then (indistinct). But
I would still go out,
because I was a general.
For I was doing...
You know.
That's the part I learned.
I didn't like to see
nobody else do it because,
I couldn't see young
dudes losing their lives,
or take somebody else's life,
and I know that blood
I gonna be on my hands.
And I ain't like that, so...
I kinda like, dropped out of the way,
and I thought it was gonna be better,
but only made it worse.
Because now, you gotta
do us a number. You know?
Try to test the steelo.
And I gotta go deep underground. Uh. Uh.
Knock 'em down and get out the way.
That was in Miami.
A few of those.
- How much prison time
have you done, overall?
- I did 14. I did seven
straight, then I did
10 in '85. For a fake
robbery the police put on me.
I did eight years and
nine months off of that.
I did a couple years,
where they used to do year
straight violations. When you do something
you get a year flat.
I did about like three
or four of those. Not at the same time,
but like, cause the most you could do...
- They had a program...
- Yeah and uh... A little county time.
Fighting cases and beating 'em.
Man, I'm 52. I think I at least, I did
I did over 30 years.
- That's half your life.
- Huh?
- That's over half your life.
- Pretty much.
- You... you have kids?
- Five.
- Five kids?
- Yeah.
- You see 'em?
- Yeah, I see 'em. Since I been on...
See, when I... When I dropped out
of life, you know. I was working, but
all that time I did, you know,
that's just rehabilitation.
Yeah, it just make you more angry.
Because when I'm
rehabilitating that much anger,
and when I got out, all the
jobs I worked, you know...
Sometimes, I might do something wrong.
Maybe I didn't. You know, way I see it,
I didn't do nothing wrong,
but you know, managers.
They come, they flex. Like
real kinda out of line.
You know it make me like, hold up dude.
Fuck you. We get in the parking lot,
I'm fucking you up. Bust yo shit up.
I'm gonna put a hole in yo head,
as big as the Grand Canyon.
That motherfucker gone tell the... Ha. Ha.
They go tell somebody,
and... and they like
man, we gotta... you a good
worker but we gotta let you go.
Was you really gonna do that to the...
Yeah, I was. Fuck him. I'm not his kid.
Yes. I worked and uh,
my kids, they love me.
I love them. They constantly, you know.
They stole my phone again.
I done had eight phones
stolen in two months.
Nine, now.
My phone is on it's not used
for no females. None of that.
Just for my kids. I love my kids,
and I keep it just for that,
and I love talking to em.
And I know I'm not gone
be here too much longer,
because life gotta leave.
- What's the closest you've
ever been to being killed?
- I done been in gunfire,
the home where we was at
was at the East Coast Crips.
And right on Seneca, hit the corner,
and we always watching. But...
We underestimated our watching,
because we look for... okay
if it's one person in the car
they ain't too much gonna
do nothing. They driving,
but what about the passenger ducking down?
You don't see 'em, and
that's how they rolled
up on us.
And it was so close, I
could tell you the numbers
that was on that fucking gun.
- Um.
- And let off. Hit my boy
twice in the ass cheeks.
But I had bullets... I had long hair then.
I had a permed hair. I
had...Like, I felt all of em like
I'm hit. I'm hit. And my
homegirl was like where, where?
I'm taking off my clothes.
They like you ain't hit.
Fish like, I am. Excuse
me, the homie's like I am.
He had two in his butt cheeks.
Yeah, That night we went... We hit four
different Crip hoods, at
one time. Simultaneously.
Y'all go. Y'all go. Y'all go. We going.
We would hit em like that.
He told me, he say, If
I don't hear no fire,
none of that, I'm getting all y'all.
- You guys did a drive by?
- That made the news.
Yeah.
- Wow.
- One time, one of the
homies, he was shermed up,
and he grabbed a cat by the tail,
and he slung and bust the cat.
I shot em.
Mother fuckers got mad
at me for shooting em.
I said, you see what he did with that cat.
Cause he coward.(Indistinct)
Cat his homies.
And they kept telling him I shot at him.
They told him. Ha, ha.
- Ha. For beating up on a cat.
- Naw. The dude beat up on a cat.
- Yeah...
I shot him for that.
- That's what I'm saying.
You're for...for...
- And I shot them for like going with em.
Cause he was they generation.
See, dudes... when
generations get together
they like to vote somebody in
they generation to take over.
You know, but they not
powerful enough to take over.
Then you got to be powerful
enough to show em that,
this is what a takeover gone look like,
y'all try it again.
His demonstration was a cat. Aah.
Bow! Bitch, get the fuck off the...
Leave the fucking... what? Bop!
But, I didn't shoot to kill, I shot em.
You know, I should have killed em.
They end up turning some
Crips hoods on us, anyway.
- You killed before?
- Yeah. I killed.
I'll kill today if I have to.
And tomorrow, next year.
If I was in my casket,
and I had to kill, I'll
wake right up out that
motherfucker and go
killing. When I got to kill.
- Is killing something you can...
you can just... do and move on?
Or is it something you carry
with you and think about a lot?
- Its something that convicts
me day in and day out.
- You go to bed, and you think about it?
- I go to bed, I wake up, I don't sleep.
Only time I sleep, is when
I can't stay up no more.
This what's helping me to stay up.
When I got this, I can watch everything,
cause ain't nobody my friend,
and I don't believe in friends.
Friends ain't nothing but a word,
to let you lower your guards,
and a motherfucker kill you.
Cause a bitch ain't no good.
A bitch will let a motherfucker
in while you sleep.
I'm a real killer, so I learned
a lot by the shit that I do.
And bitches done let me
in, while niggas sleep.
After I give 'em some good dick.
Get high, and a bitch will
do damn near anything.
Bitches ain't... look
man. Bitches are the one
that gave us away, back in Adam and Eve.
Bitches helped us to
become where we are today.
Where we was eternal.
Bitch told Adam to go
eat the fucking apple.
Then he went and ate the fucking apple.
Bitches man! You can't trust them, and so,
when you lie next to one,
trust me when I tell you this.
You can't be trusting. Keep one eye open.
It's hard, but keep one eye open.
You might learn something.
You might learn something
that make you like... And you
might be a killer after that.
Ha ha. Hey! You might
be a killer after that.
- Hmm.
Real shit.
- So do... do you have uh,
regrets of you life of gangs,
or violence and all that?
Or is it just the way
you... the way it is?
It is what it is.
- I do got regrets, but it's too late.
I can't take it back. I meant that.
Did that, Can't take it
back. That's what it is.
Yeah, I got regrets like
man I shouldn't have
did this shit but fuck it.
Move forward, let's go.
You know how motherfuckers
say man I going through hell.
I tell em, well then you keep going.
Till you get to the exit,
cause you had to enter
to go through hell, now keep
going till you get to the exit.
And don't just sit up in it
in your pity. Keep going.
That's all I can give you right now man.
I got some scary shit,
but I don't wanna give you too much, man.
Cause it might be incriminating.
I guarantee they will come
down here looking for you,
and make you a motherfucking
witness against me.
- Ha ha.
- I'm telling you.
- All right. Respect.
- Yeah, I can tell you some shit, man.
- (Indistinct)